I recently broke up with my friend Evan
best friends with same girls since we
were sixth grade and it's different and
it's sad but I mean I'm ready to put
myself out there for all my friends my
family my boyfriend is still in Georgia
I tend to do more activity driven things
because I'm trying to find someone like
me can't believe I'm doing this but I am
going on a bestfriend date today I'm not
so good at making friends I'm good at
once I had the friends funny things to
do I don't really know what to expect
with today I guess I'm a little excited
a little unsure we have been married for
10 years and don't get me wrong she's my
everything she is my best friend but I
want someone else I can go out with
besides my wife a best friend is someone
that's just gonna be there for me that I
can't rise you have to go above it
dependability I kind of like this kind
like the first date you know I gonna
have with my wife you know just like oh
god it's person gonna like me
[Music]
[Music]
five years okay yeah ten years I've been
with my fiancee for six years yeah how
did you know she was the one it just
everything is just seems so effortless
like this seems right yeah we have any
[ __ ] work every advice it just comes
down to like the bond you have with her
are you working - yeah but I was
and it was even better than I thought it
was gonna be it was so much fun I loved
it we like clicked right away so yes
definitely weird bunny hanging out at
first I was uh I was very nervous but uh
it worked out pretty well my favorite
part was when we tried to do a loops and
failed miserably I think we already have
some plans to hang out again I'm glad I
put myself out there I'm very lucky to
have him as my friend
i'ma try this nothing's gonna work